[Музика]
привіт мої дорогі друзі,
я дуже щасливий знову бути тут з вами,
мене звуть Олена, я думаю, що ви всі це
пам'ятаєте, і у нас
урок англійської мови в 5 см. Попередній
– Nova Yahoo  якщо syriza dr.  Summers new
yoga units novel rockin, будь ласка, використовуйте
більше атомної брехні P, але загалом перше,
що я хочу, щоб ви зробили як завжди
перший слайд, це щось незвичайне,
ви можете побачити тему насправді на
екрані, це називається святкування та
фестивалі у Великобританії  Я думаю, що всі
знають, що таке Великобританія, їхнє Сполучене
Королівство, так, тож це не лише Англія,
а й Сполучене Королівство, і ви
побачите кілька цікавих
заяв про якісь незвичайні чи звичайні
святкові урочистості та фестивалі
в Сполученому Королівстві, і перша
робота для вас – це  щоб сказати,
правдиві вони чи неправди, чи Японія ми відкладаємо
бюджетник Нам мікрон докази правильні
святкування та фестивалі у Великобританії
лікар сказав, що кубанія, якщо фестиваль уникнути
забруднення, амакура, пряма трансляція тут
Персіваль Паван є відносним oppa bottom
вони прийшли трахали брата піхву бонус, який
носака Ваня  Фестиваль традиційний
згоден Ніккі поширеність забруднення амок
рельєф Вулиця навіть Петрівна Хаддад
шпаргалка Vi  rginia тут проф.  Деві
Чінні
добре, тож давайте прочитаємо першу, і
я буду використовувати своїх помічників, мою фальшиву картку
та свою справжню картку, щоб сказати вам
, фальшиві вони чи правдиві, тому перша
продається у Великобританії, люди святкують
день млинців ті, хто бере участь у
перегони повинні проходити на сковороді
з млинцем або дже-йонг мадхуматі
дешево округлі кажуть, що забруднення амакура в
прямому ефірі тут, у заварному кремі Кавані
на ключовому фестивалі, виродка ділить
сито, якщо вона обіцяє, що сьогун
завжди супер роговий, який  підлий
Павіні будь пихатий чи Патель унікальний навіть
у віддаленому місячному морі, повинен сказати зонд
Чейні, що ви про це думаєте, тому я
скажу вам правильну відповідь, це
абсолютно вірно, і це одне з
незвичайних свят і свят, які
люди відзначають у  Великобританія я пишаюся тим,
що це мій рік, коли я створюю каву
в своєму кавовому закладі, якому потрібно, щоб виродок уникав,
чиї забруднення шаленіють, знімають стрес, що
охолоджується добре, давайте прочитаємо наступний
у Великобританії кожній іменинниці чи боці  y
нехай феєрверк на його день народження
бля з дієтою причиною нада Тіна : a de
niro Ginga the poo sky ми працюємо
лайно проблема що ви думаєте
звичайно це неправда,
перш за все це справа смаку
не всім подобається  феєрверки, а
по-друге, це може бути дуже небезпечно
писати, так що, звичайно, це не традиція,
це не обов’язкова умова на кожен день народження,
і не кожна іменинниця чи хлопчик випускають
феєрверк, це неправда, а
як щодо того, що у Великобританії люди
святкують Різдво 23 числа  грудня
не знаю особистих кухарів забруднення
амакура живе нижче світка,
який у всьому світі окремо ви Харуна
лайно схвалив дозвіл має Ванкувер
мутований Садат звичайно це
неправда, тому що я думаю, що всі
знають, що люди у Великобританії та в багатьох
інших  країни святкують Різдво
25 грудня, так що одне
неправда, давайте прочитаємо цей, який весело
катати сир
, це щорічний фестиваль весни, що
вона катає ха  чи ви чули про цю
традицію, чи чули ви про
свято весни, як про те, що вона ритуально
вживана сироваткою, що причиною є те, що вона спринцює Мішну, метод шабба-ду
ще не є ключовим фестивалем, на якому
майже слід сказати, що дуже гаряче я
скаже вам, що це правда, що це проблема,
і вона котиться - це щорічний фестиваль весни,
а трохи пізніше я
розповім вам про те, що поспіх зберегти це
neshama prayaga poha теплий ой і
останній st.  День Святого Патрика —
офіційне державне свято в Ірландії, його
відзначають 17
березня, що ви думаєте про те,
що ви чули про св.  День Святого Патрика,
якщо ні, ви можете правильно погуглити, це так
приємно просто погуглити інформацію, яка
може бути для вас новою, і дізнатися
щось, щоб дізнатися щось нове, тому,
якщо ви не чули про вул.  Patrick's
Day просто погуглить і дослідіть це
добре або ви сказали Правда вона
Луїсвілль KU у деньша острова на горщик
привертає увагу, але кастрат
ну не справедливий на ГУ якщо ви не
сидите чи ведміть хіба не варто сказати, що пишається
ними і цим  це правда, і я думаю, що
більшість із вас це знали, тому що це
дуже популярне свято, і я думаю, що багато
людей знають про нього добре,
я хочу, щоб ви переглянули
деякі слова та фрази, які
допоможуть вам говорити про святкування
про фестивалі про свята  Doretta
Shara весна Адама плакат emoji Словацька
має suet Septimus via vine, тому
першим є святкувати через каваді
святкування
Ваня свято Джотто фестиваль фестиваль
звичай або традиція радиккіо державне
свято німці на національному символі
материнському
символі парад папуга глядачі шкіра
дешево зверніть увагу на це  слово це
може бути важко для вас ви також
перевірте, що це означає перевірте, як це пишеться
глядачі традиційні костюми готовий
tini споживач вогонь  роботи saluted racing
para horny щорічно, якщо кожен новий
магазин іграшок винагороджуватиме, це жахлива обережність, тому у
вас є час, щоб записати
слова, щоб записати переклад, і,
звичайно, ваша робота полягає в тому, щоб запам'ятати їх,
щоб вивчити їх напам'ять, тепер у мене є кілька
слів  з цього списку, і я маю деякі
визначення, тож те, що вам потрібно зробити, вам
просто потрібно відповідати визначенням
і словам у нас є глядач фестиваль
свято святкування парад Шива паб
UNITA paraquad 66 залишити глядач хула
Dodge doctors posterior є постійним
фестивалем Eastham поверх-  рівень
свята каже Beato святкування через
Vanya parade Parag хвороба ваш бізнес
енергетичний рукав термінал той, хто
відвідує та дивиться публічний показ
фестиваль парад тощо тулуб
мідним хо технікою є hromadske pas de
є MS задній високий це рух
Шоу Будди / мистецтво  фестиваль sliggoo Ваня
верхня іграшка в бік заднього вищого
відділу церемонія або святкування, пов'язане з
особливими заходами церемонія abhava
cu  banía copperud bocce pevnee ckv
Zenyatta святкування якоїсь події
подіум одягу Cavani все, що
заплановано або зроблено для того, щоб вшанувати
щось, магазин взуття la nuit так само, як і
ведучий нора, сказав, що Латур вміло показує, як
люди знизу Сітки марширують
перед глядачами  як частина
святкування або церемонії yo quanis Avaya
OS гурток Velika kilkis Loup de mer
Шервудська папуга шкіра Чарлі це
приказка так, тільки маленька параноїдна
церемонія фестиваль ти виступав проти перевороту
Ваня, так як ти називаєш це, тепер ми
повинні спробувати відповідати  слова та їх
визначення, тому глядач
Вілла ухиляється, якщо хтось є тим, хто
відвідує та дивиться публічне шоу,
глядач стверджує плакат Toyotas
привіт, тому глядач - це той, хто
відвідує перегляд публічного шоу фестиваль
святкування парад будь-що
спочатку  все що таке фестиваль церемонія
чи святкування, пов'язані зі спеціальними
заходами фестиваль використовує які
права в процесі забрав Ваня
перевіряються  Парад Кабана, Чая Паван II,
зокрема Пенроуз Роджер, нова
програма фестиваль це церемонія або
святкування, пов'язане зі спеціальними заходами.
щоб вшанувати Самсона
Джованні збудження Мелані Мозес
смачна закуска з калієм або Обамою, щоб
підняти виїмку з лука співведучий до Колумба
Баку мопед без подіа
парад
людей, які марширують перед глядачами
в рамках святкування або церемонії,
зараз ми їх перевіримо  я знову
трохи змішав їх і зіставив слова та
визначення, щоб ви могли прочитати їх
разом зі мною, щоб переконатися, що
ви все пам'ятаєте, так, цього разу я не
буду давати вам жодного перекладу,
і якщо ви не пам'ятаєте  те чи
інше слово, ви можете повернутися до своїх нотаток,
і ви можете перевірити слова в їх
перекладі, або ви можете шукати в
словнику та  також я б настійно
рекомендував вам шукати визначення, а
не просто перекладати слово за словом, ви
повинні знайти визначення, щоб
зрозуміти значення слова, а не лише одне
слово Staton для перекладу цього
світу добре О, Сусанна Джанна Будда
параквад з виселення  тиждень
Резюме Пасхального кролика innit oh boy Moshe tape
over new tisha nazar Pavarotti сказав ой
милий
асоціативний час ті отруйна
лава наші хлопці помітили дозу NACA
аллах зул-джалал німецький бізнес шиката аня
підхід до води
повітряний квадроцикл Стіва Ніппера
добре, так глядач — це той, хто відвідує
та дивиться публічне шоу
тирада публічного фестивалю тощо фестиваль — це
церемонія або свято, що включає
спеціальні заходи, свято свято — це
святкування якоїсь події парад — це
люди, які марширують перед глядачами
як частина святкування церемонії
і останнє – останнє, але не менш важливе
святкування будь-чого, що планується чи
робиться для того, щоб вшанувати щось зараз  Я
хочу, щоб ти мав невелике завдання на читання. У
мене є два листи від двох
друзів, так багато вперед. Девід Бойс, якщо
ми збережемо Rezo, це забруднення і
кораліста,
ви тримаєте petraju, це варіюється шия
Raheel забруднення omocha полегшення
над моїм задоволенням позначати demoulas, будь
це смачно для  Yuma Virginia з його
цінністю koneko, тому ми збираємося прочитати обидва,
так, це два листи від двох
друзів, які вони подорожують Великобританією,
і вони хочуть відвідати якомога більше різних
фестивалів і парадів і деяких
свят, і вони
пишуть один одному повідомлення  вони
надсилають один одному листи, де діляться своїм
досвідом та враженнями від
побаченого,
добре, тож давайте прочитаємо перше, що ми
проповідували, я людина
так картопляний бхаджан Словаччина, залиште нас
з Далілою, скажімо пропозицію через
Нашуа Баби, тому Мітч  Casa Tamara, тому привіт
,
сподіваюся, ви насолоджуєтесь своїми відпустками,
гарні
пристрої Jospeh, якщо немає
таблиць провайдерів,
учора було 17 березня і
люди  е в Ірландії святкували св.
Свята Патріка Чаура нижче стільки ж
на ягодах тепер ускользають від берлінського
району Кавала густо тоухоу частинка
це офіційне державне свято, але
не було видано спільно офіційні державні
свята на ПЗУ естетично Луї
щось це ми сховали мене там був
величезний парад у  центр Дубліна
Дублін вкрав свою героїню D це на бика
хулігани Чесні пірат погоня Лаванія люди
були національними традиційними костюмами
Лютер вважав, що наш тубіль згадав про наш
нейтралітет не
питання Зелений колір цього
свята і більшість глядачів були
зелені в одязі, коли він дарував астре
Атест BT показує нам зараз символ, щоб вести
статтю Емма під назвою Oh Judah
bhajatam, і нехай вождь повірить, що
кохана уникає Елеонори - я купив
багато сувенірів та ірландський прапор для Якопо
Бахата, сувенір, якщо такаші, я
покажу британцям про чесність olanski  недолік
феєрверк був дивовижним, я думаю, це була
найкраща частина дня, це був найкращий
день моєї
подорожі  просто поставте SS ваш soluti
точний коли використані сплави це повітряна куля я
розчавлю його МакКроскі моменти вперед не
те, що вони повинні означати, що на
італійця є єпископ, якщо ми розділимо окремо
все, що йокомо хуша, буша добре, і ми
також отримали листа від його друга та
його друга  хоче поділитися своїм досвідом,
який він мав минулого тижня - добре, тож
давайте прочитаємо лист Прітчетта,
я є відео зі списком, хо, друга, так що він
пише, привіт, мій друже, я також хочу
поділитися з вами своїм досвідом, у якому я брав
участь  дуже весела гонка Sherman push вона
закохалася в тебе бу-бу смачно
Вільяме ці свободи варити бульйон «
Ям», який хочеться
вчора, я взяв участь у святі
під назвою «День млинців», який є дивовижним
святкуванням спринту, коли ти какаєш
Алану, тримаєш  широкі груди о, ключ, її
собака Єва, але я хочу вдарити навіть
Парваті, звичайно, Наварро Кунью, коли я
взяв розділене ім'я мій головний млинець
це веселі традиційні перегони Великобританії
це вассел доджо  a / хто болить, але
готовий T у тому, як він дав буу Бельгії,
викликає нервозність забруднення амок або
помада в типових млинцевих перегонах
учасникам доводиться бігти, тримаючи
сковороду з млинцем в ній,
кидаючи млинець у повітря, так, так, щоб
вони '  повторно тримає млинець на сковороді,
і вони повинні бігти з ним, а
потім вони повинні кинути лікарю одне ім'я
, ти мені віриш, Кікі рекламуй, яка
супер вода від тварини Павіні, це
pettalia messy potamia una semilla net,
якщо ми не бачимо жодного бізнесу  навіть глибше, коли
ви вибираєте це домашнє посилання ah
elevator yo ho na Patel ні,
переможець перший досягне
фінішу, це буде Reyes Я іграшковий
топпер дешевше в мережі закінчив закінчено
ні Meenu звичайно він не зробив  виграти, але це
було дуже весело, тому що я жовтий навколо
мене, Аллах нижче робить розворот
Дельти, що з Махани, як ви бачите,
я не витрачаю час тут - так
весело дізнатися більше про цікаві
традиції, але матчі ще не підійшли
ніколи не пробував c  hild Charles Dharma a
doodoo Jessica котра не ISA pro
Tredici tkv traditi insha cryin якщо вона
дивна людина navasana selo kiss of dunya
yes miss la open sign все ж юність
Чикаго перш за все якщо плямка лози навіть
у питанні злоякісна Кім Поллі кохана
війна пропозицій  lo de aqui Proteus
Prabhavati sheshna веб-сервер ботанік Роберт де
Mowbray time Oh oppa Sanya oboe sahadev
важлива пам'ять Сомалі ключі удару
максимально не empanada Tiki або так будьте добре,
тому в цій діяльності ми маємо
описи двох фестивалів фестивалю і знову
так ми будемо ми  буде читати їхні
описи, а також у нас є дві нотатки
від двох людей, які подорожують
по Великобританії та хочуть спробувати
щось цікаве та незвичайне, тому
ваше завдання — дуже уважно прочитати
разом зі мною, а потім вирішити, який
фестиваль, який святкування використовує яку
люди  все гаразд, тож давайте
спочатку прочитаємо опис фестивалів
в останній день січня,
фестиваль вогню проходить у Шотландії був
крихітним  ith два Rock дивіться Gina спочатку
Volvo Neve з уникненням такого плану G це
передбачає парад коштує і
надає їй людей на параді
цілі смолоскипи, а в кінці
параду
я кидаю їх на великий корабель вікінгів, який
горить у  великий пожежний
чувак, якщо так, обов'язки Марацці Бонем трахається
один,
якщо подумайте про зайчика-парадо,
ви
Годар тепер задираєте Чесні жахливо
послабте його Nicky podium takács жахливий це
прекрасний фестиваль, який триває до
ранку запаморочення, яке
бачили на новому фестивалі доша карна Ніккі продакшн
кожен народ Самоа Ронко виконує
короткі п'єси на Кашьяп-авеню,
резвов уникає священика світлого роману HK пристань
пропустити це безкоштовно
це абсолютні цифри прибережні, тому це
був фестиваль вогню Себу фестиваль
Wahine shot lungi і наступний
це незвичайний  гра, в яку грають
на заході Англії телевізійної ери
Бунт Міяко, я думаю, цікавий
Антлі: великий сир котиться з
пагорба, і люди біжать за ним
що ж, це стільки, скільки мої розмови нульові цитати
поспішайте втекли від павільйону в красі,
переможцем є той, хто перетне фінішну
лінію e в'януча Італія, хіба ви не вдарили
окремим ножем, це не лінійна
комерційна обробка, це може бути
небезпечно, але це так весело  багато
глядачів любили дивитися це, я
не думаю, що ви ставите патч безодні ні
захищає doozy of solo це як я, а
не ви, хто керує заворушеннями в Ducie Baja,
щоб завантажити хокей дивитися це The Sims
posterior heart
doosre  Bahuguna, будьте дешевими глядачами, добре,
і ми маємо дві записки від людей,
які подорожують Великобританією і
хочуть спробувати щось цікаве,
щось інше, тому давайте спробуємо
знайти відповідний фестиваль або ще раз для цієї
та цієї особи
Департамент Бріджит, я не знаю,
кого  я
хотів би спробувати щось екстремальне та
динамічне та отримати багато задоволення,
о, це почалося в aqua terrible, ймовірно,
покази зменшують зайву милю, товариш,
дивіться самі
я ось  я займаюся спортом і гонками, і я хочу
спробувати щось незвичайне, це спокушає бідну
команду Налу Дена, ти вступаєш в змову з Парра,
який, напевно, тільки той, хто займається, мабуть
із сесіями, ми Китай я люблю
фотографувати, і я люблю фестивалі та
паради я говорив тобі про nodosa
ubud фотограф вечірка він робить rapido
зимовий фестиваль de parada я хотів
би зробити красиві знімки незвичайного
параду в обсерваторії чудові агітатори,
які є частиною Роберт a
harness nunca куди мені піти і що
мені спробувати хто ввів в оману бика OPP da sure
твої модулі Роберте, то що ти думаєш, що
ти думаєш на пару секунд, ти
приймаєш рішення, я думаю, що все
цілком очевидно, але все ж я даю
тобі кілька секунд на роздуми, і ось
що я думаю про це так, так як він
шукає щось екстремальне,
динамічне та спортивне, і йому подобаються перегони. Я
думаю, що ця щорічна гра, ці великі
сирні гонки, є для нього найдовговічнішою,
і вона чи вона тепер ця людина
любить фестивалі та  любить
фотографувати, тому я думаю, що це
буде найдовговічнішим, тому цій людині
слід поїхати до Шотландії і
сфотографувати прекрасне свято
вогню, а у мене є дуже особливий гість,
який є моїм другом, який дійсно
чудовий учитель  яка фантастична людина
, яка люб’язно погодилася розповісти вам
про традиції та деякі традиції, які мають
люди у Великобританії на Різдво,
тож я хочу, щоб ви зробили, ви
подивіться відео, а Mr.  Вільямс
розповість вам про традиції,
які мають жителі Великобританії, і під час перегляду
на екрані з'являться деякі запитання, тому ви повинні дуже уважно слухати,
також ви можете робити нотатки,
і як тільки питання з'явиться, вам потрібно
буде негайно відповісти на нього.
доброго ранку, п'ятий рік, доброго ранку,
міс Селена, мене звати Найл Вільямс,
і я працюю в школі в Єгипті,
зараз тут 8:15 ранку, і
ваша чудова вчителька міс Луна
попросила мене розповісти вам щось про
традиції святкування в  країна, з якої
я родом, чи може хтось здогадатися, звідки я
, це правильно, я з Великобританії і
маю чудовий британський акцент, сьогодні я
збираюся трохи поговорити з вами про
Різдво, яке є моїм улюбленим
святкуванням  Тому моє перше
запитання до вас: що таке Різдво,
чому ми святкуємо Різдво, я дам
вам кілька секунд, щоб подумати, що міс Елайна, можливо,
захоче призупинити відео, поки ви
обговорюєте Різдво – це християнське
святкування  народження Ісуса, за якого
християни вважають сина Божого,
він народився в стайні в місті під назвою
Віфлеєм, далеко від України та
Єгипту, тепер, крім релігійної
частини Різдва, ще одним дуже важливим
аспектом святкування є інший
персонаж у  У Великобританії ми називаємо його
Дідом Морозом, в Америці його називають Санта
Клаусом Я вірю в Україну, ти називаєш його,
смієшся зараз у Великобританії за два
місяці до Різдва діти пишуть
листи Санта Клаусу, запитуючи його,
що б вони хотіли в якості подарунка, вони
також пояснили йому  наскільки вони хороші
і намагаються переконати його, що вони
дійсно заслуговують на присутність, про яку вони
попросили напередодні Різдва
24 грудня, і це ще одна дуже
важлива річ, яку я можу згадати, що
у Великобританії Різдво святкується 25 числа
грудня в інших країнах, наприклад
в Україні, бізнес відзначається
7 січня, можливо, ви можете дослідити
зі своїм класом і дізнатися чому, але
у Великобританії 24 числа  грудня діти
вірять, що Санта-Клаус відвідує їх
будинок і залишає подарунки у Великобританії,
ці подарунки залишає Дід
Мороз у панчосі, який є великим
великим шкарпеткою на кінці ліжка дитини,
і вони прокидаються вранці
25-го числа.  Грудень у шквалі
хвилювання і подивіться, які подарунки подарує
їм Різдво Я пам’ятаю,
коли я був дитиною, я ледве міг спати
Я був так схвильований, побачивши, які
подарунки я можу отримати зараз, ще одна велика
подія, яка відбувається у Великобританії на
Різдво  це різдвяна вечеря, це
дуже особлива їжа, яка
зазвичай проходить у другій половині дня, її
готують дуже довго, і є
багато різних страв, які люди
готують, основним м'ясом яких є індичка, а також
індичка, є смажена картопля,
яка є картоплею  які дуже довго готуються в
олії в духовці
, дуже смачні, але дуже
шкідливі для здоров’я, є багато складних,
наприклад брюссельська капуста, ви можете
погуглити, що  ось і морквяні
нарізки ще одна важлива річ,
яка називається потертою, яку кладуть всередину
індички, коли вона знову готується, ви
можете зайти в Google і дізнатися, що це таке, у
нас також є ковбасне м'ясо, яке є
ще одним типом м'яса, який знову додається
до індички  Ви можете захотіти
погуглити й дізнатися, що це таке, і
все це вкрите гарним м’ясним соусом
для підливи
зараз на десерт або для пудингу, як ми
його частіше називаємо у Великобританії, є
різдвяний пудинг, який схожий
на великий фруктовий пиріг і  Особлива особливість
: коли мій батько приносить його
до кімнати, і ми всі на різдвяній
вечері, він кладе на нього трохи віскі
і підпалює
ще один маленький традиційний тиждень: ми
кладемо шматочок в 10 пенсів, який
британські грошові пенси та фунти
всередині різдвяного пудингу, а той, хто
отримує шматочок, має 10 пенсів, які їсть
всередині, отримує удачу, і ви
дізнаєтесь лише дуже обережно кусаючи, щоб переконатися,
що ви не зламаєте свої зуби, дуже
приємно було б  це допоможе добре, ще дві речі, які
я скажу, перш ніж залишити вас у
спокої, ще одна річ, яка відбувається у
Великобританії, яку всі роблять і сидять
по всій країні приблизно о 3
годині дня, ми всі сидимо і
дивимося  Королева виступає з промовою Королева
розповідає про те, що трапилось у Великобританії
цього року, і дає деякі плани та сподівання
на наступний рік. Я пам’ятаю, як дитиною
сидів із бабусею і
дивився це, проводячи доволі чудовий
час,
і останнє, що я  просто збираюся
поділитися своїм екраном зараз, щоб ви могли бачити, про що
я говорю, тому що ви, можливо, цього не
маєте в Україні, це хтось знає,
як вони називаються, це називається,
і я припиняю ділитися своїм екраном,
тепер це називається crackers  і
це те, що ми маємо поруч із нашими тарілками та
килимками на столі різдвяної вечері,
і що відбувається, ви тягнете цей
крекер, це до двох людей, кладіть кожен
крекер всередину, є подарунок,
і людина, яка отримує подарунок, є
людиною  т  капелюх досить сильно тягне крекер
і отримує частину крекера,
яка містить подарунок всередині, можливо, ви
хочете, щоб хтось захотів подивитися відео, щоб
зрозуміти, як це працює,
тому це дуже швидке відео від мене
сьогодні вранці про деякі традиції Великобританії, що
оточують  Різдво, про які
ще фестивалі ви знаєте,
які дійсно важливі для нас у Великобританії,
можливо, ви могли б дослідити це, щоб мати
чудовий день на п’ятому році та мати чудовий
день, міс Аллайн
Я добре дякую вам за
увагу, я впевнений, що  ти
дуже старанно працював, я бажаю
тобі чудово відпочити від дня, і
дуже скоро побачимося,
[музика],
ти